what's going on guys this is Rob and now
that we have finished with a story
involving the dark crisis and Justice
League incarnate we are here at the
death of the Justice League so Justice
incarnate for those of you guys who are
catching up with us are basically the
multiversal Justice League team they're
not the traditional superheroes that
you're used to seeing they're basically
versions of like Superman and so on from
alternate realities now what ended up
happening is they were unable to stop
the coming of the great darkness which
most of you guys who don't know what
that is we'll actually do a bit of a
refresher as we get further through this
video because it's explained pretty well
in this story but the other thing about
this is that Darkseid who's kind of the
like the representation of evil in its
most true form in DC Comics not taking
into account Lucifer Morningstar that he
was taken by the great Darkness so
basically what you have is this just
insanely powerful Army and again they'll
reappear in this story so those of you
guys who were playing catch up don't
worry you won't feel left out by the
time this gets done now the thing about
this is that this initially opens up
basically an earth zero remember Earth
zero is the main DC Universe in DC
Comics where you see Batman Superman and
all those guys and what ends up
happening is Black Adam along with other
members of what are basically the
Justice League Aquaman Martian Manhunter
Wonder Woman Superman Batman the Green
Lantern zatana who's basically just a
really powerful magician and hot girl
they're all essentially whisked Away by
Justice incarnate and brought to the
Justice League headquarters or at least
to the Justice incarnate headquarters
what's really kind of left of it now of
course we do get a bit of a recap which
is basically everything that I just said
a minute ago so we can kind of skim past
that but the reality is that with
Superman and these guys showing up
they're kind of flabbergasted that they
were never contacted by Justice
incarnate in the first place and for the
most part that makes sense the Justice
League as it exists in the main DC
Universe it is an incredibly powerful
team but the reality here is Justice
incarnate is more powerful than they are
because they have a variety of
superheroes a much larger roster than
the Justice League traditionally has
because you have like multiple versions
of Superman as part of Justice incarnate
really good example being like President
Superman man and then Captain carrot
who's basically a version of Superman
from a different reality just things
along those lines and so for the most
part when it comes to multiversal
threats that's the Justice incarnate's
thing it's what they handle this is a
threat of such a level that Justice
incarnate can't handle it on their own
and they've also lost some of their
number now the reason why Superman and
them are also sort of flabbergasted is
because they've dealt with multiple
crisis events remember after everything
that's happened in DC Comics in recent
years where crisis on infinite Earth and
then Infinite Crisis and final crisis
where those were all events that
basically kind of changed the the
continuity of DC Comics some people
remembered it some people didn't but it
kind of reset the universe in different
ways the truth is that with what's
happened recently everybody remembers
all the crisis events now they remember
all those events that have happened over
the course of DC's timeline and so with
all the superheroes recalling all of
that the response to Superman and them
are like we've dealt with multiple
crisis events if you got a toilet that's
clogged you don't call an electrician
you call a plumber and we're the
plumbers
terrible analogy I know but you guys get
the point the problem is that in the
middle of this whole discussion suddenly
you end up having the great darkness
that makes its move against Justice
incarnate and so what ends up happening
is Dr Multiverse ends up teleporting the
entirety of the Justice League and
what's left of Justice incarnate to
Multiverse two now remember this is one
of the things that DC established that
for years and years and years in DC
Comics pretty much their entire history
up until this moment until the dark
crisis story there was only ever one
Multiverse that the Multiverse was
destroyed during crisis on infinite
Earth the Multiverse was brought back
during Infinite Crisis and then final
crisis made the superheroes aware of its
existence it was changed during the
events of Flashpoint but it was still
only one Multiverse what DC has done
here with dark crisis is they've
established the idea that the original
Multiverse that was destroyed during
crisis on infinite Earth it continued on
it was just being fed on as a source of
energy by the great darkness and his ilk
and so we didn't know that it still
existed we thought it had been wiped out
because Infinite Crisis brought the
Multiverse back but it was a different
version of the Multiverse so kind of
Multiverse 2 is what we can really call
it that's kind of the crazy thing here
because even when the superheroes arrive
they're like okay we thought this
Multiverse was dead like how is this
thing even here and that's when they're
met by the arrival of pariah now Pariah
as he's being shown in this story is
kind of modified a little bit from what
DC's previously done with him right
originally it was him that wanted to see
the the beginnings of all creation it
was him that unleashed the anti-monitor
in the first place and it was him that
caused the anti-monitor to go on its
Rampage and basically Wipe Out the first
Multiverse during the original crisis on
infinite Earth story ever since then
Pariah has literally had to deal with
what's basically a punishment for his
actions in the sense that every time
there's a major Calamity on a colossal
scale some universe-wide event or
something like that he's automatically
teleported against his will to that
location and he's forced to watch it
happen right that's the price he pays
for basically letting the anti-monitor
loose in the first place and so as a
result of that somewhere along the line
and we don't exactly know how but
somewhere along the line the great
Darkness got its hands on Pariah but the
other thing about this is that where he
was wildly capable and he was a pretty
you know pretty strong guy his powers
have been Amplified and we'll actually
find out just how powerful he is in this
story because up to this point Injustice
incarnate and those stories Dr
Multiverse literally saying like I'm the
only one of myself across the Multiverse
right there's a whole great big huge
Multiverse only one doctor Multiverse in
it that her stance has been we cannot
mess with Pariah that guy's on a whole
different level of power we are not
ready to face off against that guy yet
right like we will get destroyed by him
if we do and so with Pariah being there
initially you have Superman doing what
Superman does right you know hey man you
know I know it sucks I mean you know
when your world was destroyed your world
was the first one that fell to the end
to the anti-monitor and you've had to
watch a whole bunch of just events where
everything dies and all that kind of
stuff and I know it sucks man but like
hey dude chill right like let us help
you out everything's gonna be cool but
of course he basically rejects that and
in doing so what he reveals is the great
Darkness basically told him somewhere
along the line the Justice League from
Earth zero is going to respond right
superheroes are nothing if not as
predictable as the Sunrise and because
of that when that time comes you need to
form a dark Army hence the reason why he
had captured Darkseid Dark Side had been
turned to the side of the great darkness
and so on because when this Dark Army
manifests it's basically some of the
most powerful beings in existence right
you have Ares the god of war you've got
doomsday Dark Side uh you've got the
upside down man who you don't really see
a lot of in DC Comics but this guy's
power is nuts right this guy is just
astronomically powerful the point that
I'm making here when it comes to this is
that on a good day any one of these guys
is a challenge for the Justice League
now they have to face all of him United
as a singular group and while while the
Justice League does have Justice
incarnate or what's left of their roster
there to help them out at the end of the
day these guys are nuts right just
remember dark by himself was enough to
take on Justice incarnate and under any
normal circumstance before you had True
Form Darkseid any just kind of alternate
reality version of Darkseid was enough
to take on the Justice League now you
have True Form dark side under the
control of the great Darkness with his
powers Amplified alongside doomsday and
the empty hand in all of these guys
right it's a crazy circumstance and so
what you end up getting here and this is
a really really cool analysis of the
situation what you end up getting here
is this Revelation that yes these guys
are serving as agents of the great
Darkness but the great darkness is not
using them to the best of their
abilities and in fact it's not even
really the great Darkness itself it's
really more Pariah who's controlling
them which really shows that Pariah
doesn't fully understand what he's doing
here and in fact Superman goes as far as
to say when it comes to Darkseid he's
not just some brawler right dark side
doesn't just jump in and start punching
people that's not what Darkseid does I
mean sure he's incredibly capable and
his punches would hurt like hell but the
reality is that under any normal
circumstance Darkseid would either be
standing back watching the event unfold
and waiting for the opportune moment to
step in or he would just be firing his
old Mega beams off at everybody and the
beams would just chase them around until
that person is dead the other part of
this is that while each of these guys
are a challenge they're not being used
to their fullest capacity in terms of
the power they possess and this is why
the Justice League is even able to go
toe-to-toe with these guys in the first
place because they start to realize that
what's going on is that with everything
Pariah is doing he's stretching his
power too thin among too many people the
truth here is that he only should have
brought in maybe two or three people and
that should have been it like the like
the upside down man empty hand and like
dark side right or something along those
lines like it only should have been a
couple instead of like five or six
because it's just way more than he's
able to manage in his power while it is
exceedingly high is not infinite and so
ultimately what ends up happening is
basically dark side is overtaken along
with the other members of the the Dark
Army of pariah but in the end what ends
up happening here is Pariah kind of hits
the bit of a pen button and literally
tells the Green Lantern Jon Stewart your
light is at the Pinnacle of its power
Green Lantern but the dark has no limit
my Army is larger than you can even
grasp thanks to Darkseid and that's what
it basically leads to the quintessence
now remember the quintessence are
basically a coming together of some of
the most powerful beings in existence
the Specter Phantom stranger who we know
virtually nothing about but is believed
that his power is just shy of that of
God right so the guy's just crazy
powerful but when the quintessence
arrives here that's when Jon Stewart's
like oh my God right because remember
the quintessence were there to keep
Darkseid imprisoned on Earth Omega but
when Darkseid killed them what it did is
allowed Pariah to take them and then
bring them into the great Darkness so
now they're under his control which
means in the midst of this entire battle
the Specter manifests now the specter's
power has waxed and waned over the years
in Marvel Comics but this guy is DC's
equivalent of the Living Tribunal who's
under the possession of an exceedingly
just high level of power and and when
the Specter launches his attack that it
takes out Green Lantern just like that
right Jon Stewart's basically done and
gone and then literally because the
Specter is here and then Oliver Queen
the Green Arrow realizes that the
antimatter machine of pariah is what's
keeping them here in the first place he
ultimately makes the move and he
destroys it and in doing so what it does
is it dissipates the ability of pariah
to control the Dark Army and that
basically leads to the Dark Army just
essentially going away now of course
it's kind of a last-ditch action
doomsday jumps in and kills Oliver Queen
because you know Green Arrow always dies
in stories like this right but Green
Arrow is now out of the picture that
leaves the rest of the Justice League
who basically start to make their move
and attempt to attack Pariah and that's
when Dr Multiverse steps in and says no
like we can't attack this guy right we
cannot do this understand this guy's
powered by the great Darkness the great
darkness is neither good nor evil but it
is a primal force of existence he
existed before all of creation and it'll
exist after you can't defeat it you
can't overcome it the best you can do is
try to put it back to sleep again but
this is a source of power that's so
extreme not even the presence the god of
the DC DC landscape just DC's version of
the one above all not even that guy
could kill the great Darkness all it
could do was form a truce that's
basically what this is but the Justice
League doesn't listen and when that
happens they launched their attack
against Pariah and Pariah kills them all
and one Fell Swoop just like that the
only person who survives the only person
that that lives past any of this is
Black Adam and that's because Black Adam
kind of off to the side launches an
attack against Pariah but here's one
thing I want you to keep in mind Black
Adam is a guy who can go toe-to-toe with
Superman right this guy can fight
Superman to a standstill and because and
that's just based on physical strength
once you start adding in things like
magic then he gets the upper hand this
guy goes to punch Pariah and nothing
happens like Pariah doesn't even feel it
it's like you hitting a brick wall it
just there's there's nothing there and
Pariah literally says like I am a guy
who survived the death of infinite Earth
do you really think a punch is gonna
hurt me and so where he goes to destroy
Black Adam this basically leads to Black
Adam basically shouting Shazam and just
having one of the lightning bolts split
the two of them right it's not enough to
destroy Pariah but it is enough to
separate the two of them but with the
entirety of the Justice League seemingly
eradicated by Pariah just destroyed with
what looked like the greatest of ease
Black Adam ends up crash landing on
Earth and when he does when he arrives
in the Hall of Justice Wally West and
those guys who are here on Earth the
kind of Reserve members of the Justice
League at the moment they end up
responding and the only thing the Black
Adam can can say the only energy he can
muster up enough to say is the Justice
League are all dead with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace